pour commencer voilà ce qui
paris
on sort papa bonsoir vote ça non
elle feint angela et ça angeli tu la
quittes pour qu'as tu m'a appelé angela
cette amère qui a choisi l saillants
j'ai là parce que on avait participé à
une soirée où il y avait un dieu là
d'avis à l'époque donc et puis elles
savent si on était à triolet la femme
d'aragon et comme la maison très intello
alors on a fait un album il faut bien
que je te fasse vivre à exploiter ta
mère est ce que je vais souvent dessiné
dans mes dessins je me souviens même que
mitterrand jour la première fois j'ai
rencontré moi ta mère est venue nous
rejoindre et il s'est mis à rire en la
voyant ils étaient armés
je vous connais d'après les dessins on
va te connaître peut-être aussi d'après
le premier dessin moi je ne sais s'il
s'est dessinée que ce qui m'entoure jeu
c'est finalement décidé que ce que que
je vois j'avais besoin d'une adolescente
je l'avais vu dans la maison alors je te
prie madame ans les pratiques et quand
je serai majeur quand je serai plus là
tu prendras genre j'ai à ma place sa
petite fille sans doute parce que quand
le devenir adulte tu vas devenir en
perdante
j'en étais sûr qu attendaient que je
crois en rien ni en dieu ni au
communisme bon jeu correspond bien à
l'époque
vous êtes tous pareils et où les jeunes
vous croyez dans vos trucs que vous êtes
bien pensants c'est à dire vous êtes
pour les droits de l'homme mais vous ne
croyez plus qu'on peut ça vous intéresse
même pas de penser qu'on peut changer la
société
nous on croyait ça bon l'été peut-être
qu'on s'en doute on ya cru en tout cas
on passe et respectable non non je suis
pas d'accord les jeunes pensent qu'il
faut changer
moi je ne sens pas ça comme ça moi je
suis pas en train de te l'entendre dire
mais ça veut dire quoi entre autres on
va peut-être dix huit races à peut-être
la maison et à si un jour je devenais
lepéniste comment tirer à gien assez mal
bas préparons nous à souffrir mais je
crois pas que ça arrive quand même et si
je voulais me marier un jour avec un
noir p d antisémite anti sémite sommes
jeunes haut-rhinois effet des noms des
deux hommes viendraient noir non la
seule chose qui me gêne pas c'est noir
je crois que toi aussi
ah oui et tu le trouves comment manger
les riques il est bien et le beau gars
il est direct way voit pas de problème
ouais ça gêne pas que jouer avec mes
joues et tu sauves pas trop à la maison
avec ma - mois et tania la petite chaîne
donc j'adore ça des femmes moi je vivrai
c'est toujours vécu entouré de femmes
deux filles deux femmes deux chiennes et
sortir ma chienne tamia tu t'es fait non
je ne me dérange pas ça me fait c'est
mon seul exercice est de descendre les
quatre étoiles et d'aller sur les
trottoirs
et puis de lui faire faire les bistrots
du parti et le féminisme de maman tu es
faible et le mien aussi
moi j'ai lutté mois pour les droits des
femmes ou piché
avorté avoir des salaires et où tout ça
c'est normal c'est normal mais c'est
vrai que ça fait chier les hommes
qu'est-ce qui t'énerve chez moi ce qui
m'énerve c'est que tu me pub est une
pique mais plus lent que hp est le
dernier c'est pas moi c'est pas toi
l'ouest en tout cas je n'ai pas trouvé
c'est pas moi l'aura du couloir je ne
sais pas où il est chez moi
qu'est-ce qui tenait matoub lit tout le
temps que j'existe sûr c'est pas vrai je
fais semblant pas comment peux-tu
comment est ce que je pourrais oublier
que tu existes 1,7
c'est pas le genre à te faire oublier
ses il faut pas avoir un père
dessinateur de presse c'est ça les
dessinateurs de presse nous sommes tous
pareils
j'en connais dans tous les pays du monde
nous sommes tous dans les nuages disent
très dangereux quand nous conduisons est
toujours préoccupée par le dessin que
nous avons à faire c'est comme ça mais
quand même on a toujours un oeil sur
vous ça protège pas de regarder évoluer
ta mère dans la maison et puis d'avoir
d'avoir un oeil sur toi lorsque tu
trimballe avec ton affreux caleçon et ya
deux ans tout frais qui me donnent l'air
de [ __ ] il faut voir comment elle et
quand elle est amusante mais oui j'ai la
chance d'avoir une fille qui il nous dit
souvent ma famille et moi que qu'elle
nous m
c'est très bien ça tire hamon